this could be like a low-level
pay-per-view where people complain about
it but it's a great card where people
talk all that mess about this
pay-per-view I'm not paying for this but
you pay for it and it turns out to be
the best card of the Year this is one of
those but it's a fight night so it's
free technically it's not pay-per-view
you still got to pay for espam plus you
know what I'm saying though it's still a
fight night you got darush versus Armen
which is a phenomenal fight Jaylen
Turner stepping in on short notice
against Bobby green absolutely love that
fight Rob font versus figorito have you
seen figorito lately
cheers old son Jack City you got Sean
Brady Kelvin gastam that's sick probably
my favorite fight on the card not Lia
Klay Guida back at it every bit of 50
years old and looking phenomenal with
the craziest gas tank of all time got
Misha Tate doing the damn thing never
mad when she fights